have you ever seen a dead body
[Music]
i know what you're doing taking a life
in your own hands
everything's [ __ ] anyways this
nice climbing rope do you have anything
less colorful
you know people [ __ ] themselves when
they die
got tarps in our 39f
[Music]
dammit
how long is this going to take that
depends
what kind of implement was it um i don't
know a key
maybe i didn't do it well i'm not sure
if
you're aware of this sir but there are
several different classes of scratch
yeah so uh what class is this okay
um we're working with uh five layers of
paint here
okay we got your
got clear base coat okay great primer
coat you got your electric coat
right right down to your straight sheet
metal
and mine is down to the sheet metal
isn't it
you know what there's no way to tell
until we open her up open her up
um i guess i'll be in the
waiting room or whatever yeah
somebody sliced her up pretty good
hmm
hmm
how long you been waiting here i'm just
here for the fan
[Music]
hello i wouldn't stare at that thing too
long it'll it'll haunt you
come on in
oh [ __ ] open concept right this
place yeah i know right come on let me
show you around
i always pictured you in more of a
suburban place like around the corner
from the frat
yeah me too but uh you know who doesn't
love a three bedroom hanging off the
edge of existence right
you don't you're afraid of heights
yeah but you know i moved in with her
michael is that you i'll be right out
give me two seconds
sort of a [ __ ] show gave her four
scripts this season
i haven't seen her in weeks what's going
on over there
uh she's bidding on some magic the
gathering card
i don't know black lotus
baby it really is a far drop
i'm just saying there's a total absence
of daytime television oriented for men
but you're talking about a talk show for
dudes you want the dude view
there's spike tv but that's just kung fu
movies and danny trejo laughing
if there were a dude view it'd be called
crotch shot
that's it i quit do you get it uh
no does the only son of a [ __ ] mean a
good thing where you're from sometimes
depends on the context
how much was your bid uh twelve thousand
dollars twelve
thousand dollars you're gonna spend
twelve thousand dollars of our money on
a
car it doesn't matter i didn't get it
anyways okay i was out bid by [ __ ]
bid bot
people should not be allowed to use
those thousand dollars
ah you're gonna frat you should be able
to open these on your forehead
yeah i guess so you would never survive
the party wilderness
i think i'll be all right they need my
econ skills i think
you know to rebuild the economy too cool
to sell your body like the rest of us
well you can't sell your body no one's
buying it
that hurt did you ever get that black
lotus card
no i have like 500 saved up but i only
need like
12 million more do you use my fafsa
money for that
like i mean that's it's kind of
imaginary right
like it's real but it's not real
no it's very real and that's not a good
idea
it's a terrible idea actually
yeah oh um
i should do what no what are you doing
you're skipping your main phase
what no like isn't it combat main then
upkeeper
no it's draw upkeep main then combat
okay well then i can do this
and then no he has summoning sickness so
you have to wait another turn
there's so many rules oh this coming
from captain cecil
[Music]
nope i like it for good leave it
have you ever seen eric you should do a
girl huh
have you ever seen eric be shitty to a
girl no more than me i guess
well come on well like has he ever
flaked on anybody
has he ever after more than three months
flaked on something um i don't
think so i haven't seen him
do it okay
i just don't want to get my hopes up
again
he's a he's a good dude you swear
speak now forever hold your peace
okay
i'm gonna get you that card what the
black lotus one i'm gonna
i'm gonna buy it for you okay
and then i'll live happily ever after
oh eric's here
so michael took a day off yeah
thought i'd get some stuff done you know
uh before my trip
oh a trip where too um
i haven't decided yet what you always
decide
like to a fault you decide things but i
just thought i'd do this one at random
um i think my uh yeah looks like my car
is
done i should probably get going um
okay see you guys you can fish your
drink hey i can give you a ride man i
just got an
uber so i'll be all right when are we
gonna see you again
i'll call you
[Music]
hey hey hey are you okay
i'm fine i'll be right michael
yeah i'm fine you're coming to dinner
with us on friday
i think i'm uh busy coming to dinner
with us on friday okay
yeah all right
[Music]
you